let's talk about President Joe Biden we
have such an unusual situation happening
in the 2024 presidential race and
particularly within the Republican
primary that Joe Biden really needs to
do only one thing to win in 2024 and
that is to not screw up David screw up
that's not very precise language what I
mean specifically is that Joe Biden
needs to avoid
self-inflicted errors and he will have I
believe a relatively clear path to
re-election in 2024 despite all of the
criticisms I've had of Joe Biden despite
concerns among many about his age if he
can manage not to quote screw up
I believe that he is going to get
reelected now you might be thinking
David that's very obvious that how does
that count as any kind of political
analysis at this point in time of course
he shouldn't mess up but let me explain
why this is so crucial in this
particular situation first of all what
about problems that aren't Joe Biden's
doing without ignoring the human tragedy
of crises we know from looking at
history that often major crisis events
like 9 11 help the president in power to
the extent that George W bush did not
heed warnings about 9 11 like we can
talk about to what degree 911 could be
blamed on Bush to some degree that's not
what I'm trying to do today but the
point is after 9 11 the country rallied
around Bush and he had a record high
approval before invading the quote wrong
country and squandering the approval so
Joe Biden doesn't have to worry from a
political perspective
about tragic events Beyond his control
he should of course work to prevent any
tragedy that that is preventable without
a doubt but we're speaking politically
here so then you get to the Republican
Party Biden doesn't have to be amazing
to win in 2024 he has to be better than
the Alternatives he has to be more
stable than the Alternatives and the
alternatives are as much of a mess as I
have ever seen the Republican party is
in disarray there is no coherent Vision
there is no coherent agenda you have a
party divided between do we want more
Trump as the magedonians or magats do
or do we realize that Trump has been a
disaster in 2018 in 2020 in 2022 and we
have to go a different way either way
you have a Republican party that mostly
exists publicly to oppose what Biden
does and say it's all terrible and do
anti-woke culture War nonsense many
still loyal to Donald Trump now under
two indictments for classified documents
federally and then the hush money
situation in New York possibly more
forthcoming indictments and then he's
running again despite the fact that he
is not particularly popular nationally
he is still extraordinarily popular as
the cult leader that he has become among
the Maga people he's actively trying to
sabotage any potential Rivals and in the
meantime you actually have a pretty
solid Republican candidate by the old
standards of the party in Chris Christie
who is polling at last check
uh Chris Christie is polling
uh where is he 1.2 percent his big
announcement last week got him from one
percent to 1.2 percent so Biden can win
simply by not messing up the economy has
to be okay and it is people have to
believe that but the economy has to be
okay and it is
um he has to be decent he has to be uh
stable and that's basically what we need
from Biden in order to see him win and
if you look at recent highly rated
general election polls nationally you
see morning consult from a few days ago
you see Biden's leading DeSantis by
three and Biden's leading Trump by two
these are not blowout numbers at this
point in time but it is really important
to understand that what's going on in
the Republican primary made to swayed
turnout in a way that is not reflected
in the polls and the presence of trump
as the nominee who seems like a shoe-in
at this point although we'll see what
happens okay I'm keeping an open mind at
this point Trump seems like a shoe-in if
Trump is the nominee there is an
intangible group of people that will
come out and say I'm not that engaged in
politics but we can't have Trump back
again and that that is not reflected in
the polls either so my sense right now
is that Joe Biden if he doesn't get in
his own way has a relatively
unobstructed path to re-election whether
I love Joe Biden as a candidate is
irrelevant you all know that I would
like to see a different candidate uh if
it was up to me but I am also going to
give you analysis that is based on what
we have and there is no indication I
mean I don't want to be dark but unless
Joe Biden dies he's going to be the
Democratic nominee I want debates I want
candidates I would love the DNC to hold
debates they're not going to it's not up
to me I can't do anything to change that
uh that is my sense of this race right
now
and over the next 48 hours we will see
Donald Trump go to Miami get arrested
booked arraigned once again he will then
speak from Bedminster tomorrow night
we're going to cover all of it and we
are going to see how do the other
Republican candidates react to that how
does Joe Biden react I assume Joe Biden
will continue saying absolutely nothing
about it which I like I like that Biden
is saying I don't have anything to do
with this independent prosecutors and
investigators are doing what they think
they need to do based on the evidence I
like Biden staying out of it and
governing that is the starkest and most
productive contrast that Joe Biden can
provide at this point in time don't
screw up
could always say that that's what they
need to do but it is so uh particularly
important right now let me know your
thoughts let me know if you agree with
this assessment